okay you guys should be able to hear me
yeah you guys should be able to hear me
if you can let me know if you can't then
um then hopefully we can get it figured
out
where's my headphones here they are
headphones are right in front of my face
okay yeah I got my headphones on them in
my safe place I always wear my
headphones when I'm at my computer so
it's like a habit to like put them on
and I always feel weird if I don't have
them on for some reason because one of
the things you guys don't know is
whenever I'm making my videos and
usually when I'm recording my videos I'm
always listen to music in the background
so that way I always have something
going on there's always something to to
keep my brain from getting all frazzled
and so on so anyway so what's up oh man
not really any questions yet which is
fun of course I'll start rolling in here
in a second for those of you guys who
were new who have never been part of
comics and coffee this is a chance for
me to basically answer the questions
that you guys have to this this is your
day out of the week to to ask me all
kinds of questions and to remove that
guy's comment and possibly ban him if he
does it again
but um there's a chance for you guys to
talk to me directly which I you know
I've always thought is a very important
element of YouTube channels for
youtubers to reach out and to talk
directly with their their fans their
subscribers you know as often as they
can and so um I figured you know I might
as well you know do it like once a week
and talk to you guys now I'm not hung
over I actually I was last night was
awful like I was over at the guy's house
and we were watching the game and we
were like oh yes we're coming back
and then UK threw it all away with three
shot clock violations a bunch of missed
shots it was had a fool so I was a
little irritated um
I'm 30 years old actually I'm 31 now
it's my birthday thank you for all the
birthday wishes by the way I was looking
to the chat before before I started the
stream and a lot of you guys were we're
going through and they were like happy
birthday rob happy birthday rob which is
really cool so I appreciate that yes
I've seen the Punisher short dirty
laundry and that was amazing like that
was that was such a good short I'm
really hoping if they reboot the
Punisher if they do The Punisher film
like they they doom in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe they're supposed to
that they will basically use that
version of The Punisher I mean one
Thomas Jane has to come back as a
Punisher there's nobody else who can
play that character like he can I mean
he just kind of solidified his ability
to play that character and the first
Punisher movie as bad as it was written
like he was able to solidify that
character pretty well and he looks like
he's the part
I mean he's not as big and bulky as as
Frank Castle normally is but he doesn't
have to be because as long as he's
written well he could still be pretty
effective and mmm
I think that that if the movies written
were written and written right jeez if
it's written well that he could be
unbelievable with his role as the
Punisher which you know we'll see what's
up but yes dirty laundry was so good
like that was so amazing okay so yeah I
really hope he is Frank Castle yeah like
he's really got a befriend Castle so um
how does it feel to have your birthday
on Easter Sunday it's weird like I've
never I don't think I've ever had my
birthday on Easter Sunday before so it's
it's kind of strange but it's kind of a
cool feeling too at the same time
because it means that I'm special
do you watch agents of shield and what
do I think of sky or anyone else could
pop up in age of Ultron
um I think sky is definitely gonna pop
up in age of Ultron so here's a problem
the Marvel's made sky and inhuman and
you can't open that box of worms and
then just keep it confined like that's
just never I guess box worms
you can't over that can of war
and keep it confined it's just not gonna
work out that way so here's what I think
is gonna have it with sky with Daisy
Johnson one which by the way I've
actually got a jug of water during this
this week's coming to coffee I'm going
to the gym all the time it feels so good
but like I constantly drink water like
I'll just drink this jug of water all
day long
I'll drink this jug and then probably
another one you know and a ton of water
all day long which is good because once
I start to slim down I won't have all
that hopefully we won't have all that
skin like hanging off and look at all
nasty and [ __ ] but anyway um oh yeah so
so Daisy Johnson so I think that what
they're gonna do is they're gonna use
Daisy Johnson to basically segue into
the Inhumans she's going to be the way
that we meet like Black Bolt and the
other Inhumans and so on and so forth I
mean obviously at this point the way the
last episode ended she is she's going to
probably the same place that Reyna was
taken and so there's she'll be gonna
meet with Reyna and Reagan is gonna be
like okay I'm not mad at you anymore
even though you look better than me
which is cool but nonetheless I wish
that joy that milk jug was full of
coffee
I don't like imagine if that would make
jug was full of coffee comics and water
but um but no I think that that she'll
segue in that but but anyway here's the
thing so I don't know if we'll really
see like Skye during age of Ultron I
think the reason why they took her to
the Inhumans is because now like she's
out of the picture like she's no longer
part of the picture like she's she's out
of there now like she's not gonna be in
age of Ultron I highly doubt it because
now she's going to whatever wherever the
Inhumans are what's going on add Advil
mister advil axe
she's the one who everything and humans
are and so she won't be in age of Ultron
now she'll probably be an infinity war
and I think that what they're gonna do
is probably gonna leave her character
out for a while they may even bring her
back in or they may like show us what
happens with her character later on I'm
not really sure what they're gonna do
there but this would be a great way for
Marvel I guess yeah from awful to say
she's not gonna be an age of Ultron but
she will be an infinity war and it's
part of infinity war she's gonna have a
far more nuanced control over her
abilities that she currently does now
she's going to be unbelievably powerful
Debu a really cool way to segue her
character in but nonetheless let's see
what Scarlet Witch and quicksilver's new
origin I heard they were mutant city
Moors so what are they okay Scarlet
Witch and and inhuman I'm sorry Scarlet
Witch of Quicksilver and are Inhumans
now and if I recall correctly I think it
was it was like all-new X but no was an
all-new accident it was whatever group
they're part of now I can't remember
baby it is its new extra mater so like
anyway they're finding Magneto and she
cast a spell that causes all the members
of her family to fall unconscious or
something like that it was really just
kind of like shoved in their stupid way
to do it but magneto didn't collapse and
so that's when it was revealed ash that
magneto is not their father and they
made them in humans after that and it
was it was stupid it was one of the
dumbest things I've ever seen
like it was it was like okay that like
they weren't even trying at that point
they were just like somebody just figure
out a way to make Scarlet Witch and
human her Scarlet Witch Quicksilver in
humans and whatever and that was it so
we were just talking about Daisy Johnson
about Skye so this converges the secret
wars are starting almost at the same
time sort of my question is is there
going to be any kind of artists
switching companies because of the
ongoing events and stuff we know that
Jonathan Hickman is leaving Marvel I
think and he's going to DC aside from
that I don't know I don't know of any of
their artists that are switching sides
or anything like that I think that that
one stickman
I think he's when he finishes Secret
Wars is either when he finishes Secret
Wars where a secret war starts
he's leaving Marvel and going to DC but
it's sometime around that like it's his
decision is based on Secret Wars I think
it's when time runs out like when the
whole series is over that he's going
uncanny Avengers yeah that's what it is
I'm thinking that's when they that's
that's when Jonathan Hickman is leaving
and and going to going to DC how do you
want the Netflix characters to be
handled in the MCU the defenders well um
here's a problem the defenders were like
a small-time version of The Avengers so
to speak it was some of the characters
that people enjoyed but that you
couldn't put in reasonable circumstances
like I think the original defenders were
the Incredible Hulk dr. strange Silver
Surfer Fire Lord maybe and somebody else
I can rough top my head that was bad I
was way back when but those are those
are that's that's a group that it's it's
interesting that they're kind of
changing it up what I'm really hoping
they do with the defenders and this
might go against some of the things that
people really love about the defenders
proper or about the characters that are
going to be the defenders in the Netflix
series is I'm really hoping they keep
them I'm hoping they keep them street
level hoping that they keep them you
know more grounded yeah I mean we've got
the Avengers fighting aliens and going
on to space we've got the guardians of
the galaxy doing cosmic stuff then my
karna miser never be empty I appreciate
it
I really hope the defenders just stays
street level like I'm really hoping they
deal with like street-level crime
street-level villains because I think
that it'd be very very easy for Marvel
to basically wrap everything up into
cosmic level events and that's the
problem that a lot of people have with a
current run of Marvel Comics is there's
so many things that are cosmic level
guardians of the galaxy in the x-men
with black vortex and you know guardians
of the galaxy stories and the Avengers
and infinity and you know all that kind
of good stuff
you know those cosmic stories are cool
but people like stories they can relate
to I think I think people like stories
that they can look at and say like I
could easily be caught up in a situation
like that I mean - superpowers and stuff
like that but they like more grounded
stories and I think that that cosmic
level things should be once in a blue
moon and if they're gonna do the
defenders right at least for me I think
they should do them you know more
grounded more reasonable but what do I
think the post-credits scene in age of
Ultron is going to be definitely
spider-man we talked about this during
the last time we did comics in coffee
and I gotta tell you guys I can't think
of a single circumstance where they
wouldn't have spider-man I can guarantee
it was probably gonna be something maybe
Adam warlock related or maybe Thanos
related Thanos gets an infinity gem in
his hand or maybe you know use
collective memories got like three of
them or something like that you know
whatever the reason whatever the case
may be but as soon as they got the
ability to put spider-man in the MCU
they went right back to the drawing
board and I said somebody come up with a
post-credits scene it's
be good and make it happen fast and
that's probably what's exactly what's
happening so let's see can I explain
black vortex uh I'm not a big fan of
black vortex to be honest like I'm not
too into it my cortex was decent enough
but I don't I'm not a big enough fan of
the current one of the x-men or the
guardians of the galaxy then I was
inclined to pick up like vortex but I
may read it I mean Betty says it's
really good so I may read it and it may
see you know see what it's about comics
back in 80's 205 we're great mountain
out comics and my opinion are just a
soap opera your thoughts to a degree
they are I think that one of the great
things about Marvel and even DC Comics
so again I'm not not too familiar with
DC in the 80s was that with Marvel
Comics especially you you're like there
were basically building blocks like
everything that Marvel was doing in the
80s was building to how great the 90s
were the nineties were just a byproduct
of how great the 80s were in comics I
mean you got to think you got
Claremont's entire run of the x-men in
the 1980s I mean that that is that like
established the x-men that made the
x-men like mainstream that's why the
extra men stories were so awesome coming
out of Claremont run because they had
all this build-up they had all this
character definition like we knew who
Cyclops was we knew stolen we knew all
these characters on such a personal
level because it was it was basically a
way to to make things more intriguing to
make things more solid the issue here
was going after this after the 1990s all
that was used up and so it just kind of
went from there
all right somebody said the the audio
and the video is out of sync is that
true
it shouldn't be but if it is let me know
and I'll try to try to get it back in
sync it shouldn't be out of sync it
should be pretty solid let's see
but um let's see do I think the Beyonder
they got her into a tree will be
important now I think it's just a way to
write out like the ex nihilo and all
those good all those characters star
brand and all that stuff none of us
think for you nope it's fine nothing to
worry about
happy bday Rob is fine here okay well I
mean people seem to say it's fine and
those who say it's a little bit but it
doesn't really matter that much so okay
cool um as long as you as long as it's
not like like five seconds out of sync
as long as it's not you know horrendous
then then we're fine um anyway so um
who's my all-time favorite kind of a
character this century Robert Reynolds
let me tell you guys something for those
of you guys who were new and comics and
those of you guys who have Marvel
unlimited if there's any story that I
would suggest and in fact like Sal's now
has a new series on his channel called
fan favorites where he basically he's
reaching out to like me Vinnie and
himself and I guess he's reaching out to
himself
um he's basically having people and I
think it really is the main focus is
gonna be on him and other people that he
knows but they're going to be talking
about their fan favorite stories what it
is what stories they love the most and
it's gonna be like a minute and a half
to three minutes something like that um
I told him my favorite was the century
Robert Reynolds if you have Marvel
unlimited the century like the five-part
series this century and even like the
three or four tie in comics I think they
weren't really tie-in tour just kind of
like one offs to expand and give
credence to the whole century thing that
like that is one of some of the best
comic book reading you're ever gonna go
through like it is there's this some of
the best story that over in like I loved
Marvel Knights this century like as soon
as I picked it up I could not put it
down like Hall Jing is in jail II we're
like the one-two punch of counting books
with that story it was it was
unbelievable it was pretty solid the
century and blue Marvel are awesome
blue marbles pretty awesome he doesn't
he's woefully under used but he's uh
he's pretty awesome um hey Rob will you
and very a comics ever work together on
a video I'd love to at some point but
the problem is that we're super busy
like here's the thing you guys got to
remember with convergence and secret
wars coming up like conversion starts
the next week converges issue number one
is the next week that's one that kicks
off a secret war starts in May issue
number one comes out in May I think May
second which is free comic book day and
then issue number two is the one that
takes us through all the all the things
all of the the realities and I guess the
world's all that kind of gets so it's
like a big tour of metal world but we've
got to do like time runs out we got a we
got a few things we need to do before
then and some of the characters like
like superior Iron Man are probably
gonna be included so we've got to do
like superior Iron Man and and so on but
but no like like our schedules are gonna
be stupid busy they're gonna be
ridiculously busy and one thing you guys
are gonna like though is mr. Sunday
movies is coming onto the podcast
tomorrow so it was supposed to be so
hopefully you guys will hopefully you
guys will take that but what do I think
of convergence number zero I think the
fact that I had to make a video can
explaining a single issue of a comic is
a problem I usually try to steer away
from explaining like single issue comics
I don't like explaining a single issue
of a comic because nine times out of ten
comics aren't one-offs they're usually
like a big huge they're part of an
expansive story a part of an ongoing
story but the problem is with
convergence issue number zero I was
reading through it I had to read it
three times like three or four times to
make it make sense and I was like okay I
can guarantee there's a whole bunch of
my subs out there a bunch of my fans out
there who were confused as hell about
this this comic like what they're saying
what's going on because Dan Jergens
didn't do anything to help out anybody
understand what was going on and so I
was like okay so I was like I should
probably make a video explaining this
and some people will say okay let's
hopefully this this makes sense after
the video is done so are you watching
flash and arrow on the CW yeah like
flash and arrow are amazing I mean
they're flash and arrow were so good
they've gotten so much better than they
originally were like when flash for
came on I was like okay this is gonna be
kind of hokey and I watched the first
with arrow is a little bit different but
when I watch the first episode of arrow
I was like isn't bad and I watched it
like the first few season they're the
first you have to say that's all that
this is actually kind of cool like he's
killing people which is kind of cool you
know it's it was more like a trumped up
kind of thing I gave it some time and
they just grew on me and now like is as
soon as like the the stories kick off
like I'm sorry as soon as the episodes
come out on Hulu like I'm immediately
watching them so so they're they're
solid let's see do I read DC comics
since there's no DC unlimited yeah I
read do you see as often as I can but
the fact that there is no DC unlimited
makes it difficult to do older stories
which is one of the reasons why I'm glad
they're bringing these older stories
back with convergence because now we get
to explain them I mean they're gonna be
like a series of two issue stories I
think so I think you make a bad guy I
appreciate it
ah see do I think spider-man will be in
Civil War most definitely I mean Civil
War is the most anticipated movie Marvel
has coming out probably more so than
then age of Ultron this is this is the
funny thing everybody was looking at
Avengers 2 age of Ultron like oh my god
it's gonna be so cool another Avengers
film and then Marvel says like hark and
alas guys we have the rights I need to
plug in my used to graphene they say we
have the rights to are not really the
right we have the ability to include
spider-man and any movie of our choosing
and then the the rumor mill started
churning stuff out and one of the things
remember turned out was that Spiderman
was gonna be in Captain America 3 and
that immediately set Captain America 3
to the number 1 spot people were like oh
my god I can't wait for Captain America
3 to come out so I think the hype train
kind of made Marvel's decision for them
in the sense that they were like well I
guess we might as well having happen
America 3 so they're probably gonna put
him in there I can't I mean unless he
has unless they went back and just like
threw him into a scene in age of Ultron
which would be amazing that'd be pretty
awesome but nonetheless you know I think
I think Captain America 3 is when we
will have
um spider-man in the MCU let's see
Rob wanted to get your thoughts on the
end of Avengers 43 Tony off to Saul's
hammer and the rogue planet well the
rogue planet I think is a planet that
was shifted that was the planet they
shifted out of phase
but Saul's hammer is basically like the
Dyson Sphere that Tony built if you
remember all the way back to incursions
when they were working on their
individual projects Tony Stark was
building a Dyson Sphere that would
channel the energy of the Sun and would
destroy planets and and that I think is
is what he's going to harness the power
of to destroy the Shiar I guess or to do
something but at this point it's not
gonna matter I mean everything's ending
like it's all cracking down so chances
are the Shiar will be blown up and and
that'll be that like it won't make that
much of a difference let's see hey Rob
what comic comics stories or arcs would
you like to see as animated movies oh
that's a good question because I've
thought about a few of these I've
thought about a few of these you know
which ones would I like to see well
definitely well now I can't think of any
I thought about a litany of these Oh um
The Killing Joke needs to be a animated
film that would be amazing I would say
not to the owls in court of the owls
which we will finish line of the owls
don't worry guys I will probably
finished out of the owls much
convergence ends because new 52 picks up
after convergence I would say rage of
Ultron will probably make a good
animated film region Voltron was decent
enough but rage of Ultron was just like
like Marvel saying like hey guys here's
how Ultron's gonna be in a Marvel
Cinematic Universe basically it um and
the fact that he becomes I guess like
Inkpen becomes Ultron at the end I don't
know like Ultron has a harness it's
weird
let's see yeah the only only a few I can
think of up top my head um they didn't
have like a brightest day in darkest
night animated series today I mean I
don't think they did
if they did then like I didn't see it
and I need to do I think Vulcan will
come back or probably not there's no
need to bring him back I don't know why
they would bring him back anymore I mean
nobody would really care about a story
involving the third summers brother that
Tom's come and gone I don't think people
would really really care that much Age
of Apocalypse with a voice cast from
exponet series but the problem is a guy
that played apocalypse next when the
animated series that the guise of the
voiced him I think he died so they
couldn't bring him back which would that
would suck I mean I had that guy was
like the voice of apocalypse like ever
what his name was but he was the voice
of apocalypse and he was amazing
Mike isn't the Marvel Animated universe
on par with the DC Universe because
Marvel has the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and they don't need to be on par but
there are some movies that are actually
really good from the Marvel animated
universe the Doctor Strange movies
really really good
The Avengers Assemble series was really
really good like those were those were
awesome awesome things yeah I don't
think there was a brightest a movie so
far that would be really really cool to
see please answer
do you play maa sorry for spamming
real sorry I don't know what maa is I
don't know what you mean how do you feel
about the x-men having their own
universe after Secret Wars we'll see we
don't know exactly how this is gonna
play out they've been very very like
touchy on this they even very like
honestly not very forthcoming with that
I know we're gonna have Xfinity - and
who's gonna be like an x-men universe
that's separate but I don't know what
that means I don't know how it's gonna
play out I'm excited to see it yeah I
love the x-men as much as anybody else
the X would have dropped off in recent
years but the x-men will always have a
special place in my heart because when I
was a kid that's how I got into comics
was the x-men so I'll always love the
x-men but I'm just kind of curious to
see what all they're gonna do I'm kind
of curious how it's gonna play out
and my Batman no no I'm not that man
how many ant-man movies do you think
Marvel's going to make um honestly the
here's the problem with with him doing
ant-man like I think ant-man will be
good in its own right I think
be pretty solid I think it'll it feels a
lot like guardians of the galaxy we see
a lot of you guys who I guess who were
who were getting in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the guardians of the galaxy had
a long running history in Marvel Comics
but the guardians of the galaxy from the
film was a relatively new group they
showed up after annihilation I think it
was and I know start already been around
a little bit before then but basically
they should have after annihilation
that's when the group came together they
all had their individual stories before
then they all had their own thing going
on before then but still like that's
when the team formed with ant-man
I mean he's you know Scott Lang is a
relatively new character I mean well not
really he's been around for a few
decades or so but you know he's a newer
character he's not as always Hank Pym
you know we can throw that out there but
I think much like guardians of the
galaxy people are kind of unsure about
it but people are also focusing on other
things that's why like when I saw
ant-man I was like well that's cool but
like I'm really waiting for Avengers age
of Ultron I'm really waiting for Captain
America three Civil War and that's the
attitude that people have and so when
age of Ultron comes out people are of
course going to go see ant-man and I
think ant-man is going to prove to be
pleasantly surprising to a lot of people
I think they're really going to enjoy
the character of Scott Lang assuming
they keep him in line with the character
from the Marvel Comics now what I'm
hoping they do is they use the Scott
Lang from from one of the ant-man like
the the current run of ant-man from
Marvel now I'm hoping they use like that
variation of his character where he's
kind of humorous but he's also kind of
serious and he's kind of unsure of
himself but he also knows it like he
needs to do what needs to be done and
that kind of thing or they make him very
human
I'm really hoping they they go with that
let's see did I read on Canon humans
numbers you know I haven't read uncanny
Inhumans yet I know it's supposed to
come out of out of the current run of
inhuman but I haven't uh I haven't read
it let's see hey Rob happy birthday
what Lantern Corps would you want to be
a part of the Red Lantern Corps rage all
that power no I don't want to be a
probably part of the the like the White
Lantern Corps or I guess the White
Lantern get like the white ring or the
Green Lantern Corps
let's see Rob did Hydra infiltrating
shield
that hydrogen intro okay
did hydrant infiltrating shield in the
comics I assume you mean to ask like did
that actually happen yes that happened
but what's going on right now in Marvel
Comics I'm sorry an agent of shield it
seems to be more in line with Nick Fury
vs shield where the life model decoys
took over shooting it over that kind of
thing let's see
are we the homies everybody's my homie
he's like all my subscribers are my
homies it feels weird like I used to say
that when I was younger like back with
her okay so here's the other thing let's
go on a road trip since it's my birthday
let's go on a road trip back to the past
back to when Rob was a little kid like I
used to live in Seattle when I was
younger before my parents divorced when
I was around 11 or 12 years old and and
living in Seattle was awesome and I
thought I was the coolest thing but like
I was always trying to fit in and I was
just the odd kid out and so like instead
of calling people foo like like I has a
foo which is what we used to say back in
the in the 90s I'd call them like a fool
and people would be like man you're an
idiot but I was good at basketball which
was cool but yeah man let me tell you
something guys like for those of you
guys who didn't grow up in the 1990s so
those were guys who were born in nine
he's like in the late 90s who grew up in
the 2000s you guys missed it like you
guys missed it so bad like the 1990s
were amazing we had stain washed jeans
we had Fanny patch we had the talk boy
we had the Sega Genesis II see it wasn't
like an always block like it is now you
couldn't like play with your friend over
Xbox Live if you wanted to to like play
video games with your friend you had to
go to his house like you had to be like
okay I'm gonna like like can I come over
like you had to ask there ask their
parents you know can I come over and
play or can I come in and play like Sega
Genesis or Super Nintendo and you had to
pray to God that your friend wasn't
grounded and so you guys could play
together now eventually I got my own
Sega Genesis of my own Super Nintendo
but I mean like like the 90s was all
about like person to person interaction
like you had to like talk to people you
know and and so on now
like like I walk around and people are
just like on their phones all the time
like it's just
it's crazy um I slide bracelets oh my
god slappers oh my god did you stretch
them out and Wow and they'd roll right
up man I missed those things oh my god
see you guys know what I'm talking about
the 90s man pogs oh my god I had pogs I
had I had calorie book pogs back in a
day like I had I had comic pogs I had
been the animated series pogs
I had one that was gold and it was like
that thick and I have no idea what
happened to him but pogs were so cool
and they were just like collectibles
apparently he could like play like I
guess you could like play the play pogs
but like I never like I never learned
how to play I just bought them and
collected them because all my friends
had them you still have pogs oh my god
I'm 31 so but anyway so so back back to
the topic at hand Avengers versus New
Avengers who do i side with i side with
the new avengers and i assume you're
asking for like the whole incursions
thing like which ones making the right
decision which ones doing what needs to
be done i side with the new avengers for
me here's a reason why I think Captain
America is an idiot for taking the
stance that he's taking for saying that
we should not destroy other worlds
because you know like their life you
know and and that's stupid like we don't
know who's on those worlds and in that's
that's the kicker the Captain America
doesn't know like Captain America on one
hand would say okay these people need to
be able to stay alive like they need to
be able to live because they have their
own Universal own world we shouldn't
kill innocent people but on the other
hand he has no idea if the incursion
that's about to happen and the world
that's showing up it's filled with like
the opposite of the Marvel Comics like
it was like another version of the
cancerverse
where they're gonna show up they're like
hey we're just like evil versions of all
of you and we're just gonna like kill
you all like they don't know that
Captain America doesn't know that and so
Captain America would say well you know
we can't destroy that world at whatever
that's nonsense at the end of the day
the stance that I would take is the same
stance that everybody in the Illuminati
is taken like it sucks for their world
and I'm sorry about their luck but we
gotta we gotta watch out for our own
and if earth pops up in the stratosphere
out in space we're like oh my god was
another planet and an eight I was just
gonna hit us I'm sorry about their luck
but that place is getting blown to
smithereens and there's no beef about it
that's just all there is to it so I
wouldn't feel I wouldn't feel that bad
now named or lost his lost his mind
for those of you guys who who are I
guess who were familiar with time runs
out who are current with time runs out
just ignore this necks a little bit but
but for those of you guys who aren't and
we'll cover this during our time runs
out video after the after the Illuminati
kicked name war out of out of the group
which we had covered her on our
incursions video because he destroyed
the the Great Society earth he went on
and formed his own cabal so we had
Proxima midnight II at Thanos he had a
Corvus glaive he had a couple of the
people I think and they went through and
just like started annihilating worlds
like just white like they they didn't
just wait for the incursions to happen
they started seeking out other worlds
and annihilating them entirely and
destroying them and then the Cabal just
kind of started losing their minds and
they started fighting each other which
is what you expect when a bunch of
villains get together and start fighting
one another and even even Namor had
reached out to dr. doom and was like hey
man like I need you to like step in here
and he's like sorry about your luck you
should have picked a better team um he
was really cool though the way it all
played out but but that's just one part
of time runs out there's a lot of stuff
that happens after that there's star
brand and there's the extra halos and
all that kind of good stuff but then Wes
um yeah it's it gets crazy like it's it
gets crazy like time runs out it's but
see here's the problem the time runs out
has like these big lo periods where
there's like like nothing happens
nothing that matters happens but in
order to make you in order to make the
end of time runs out makes sense like
we're gonna have to explain all that
stuff so we're going to talk about star
Brandon those guys but you know
nonetheless what we might do is we're
trying I'm trying to figure out how I'm
gonna do time runs that will get it
sorted out so that it'll make sense
another time secret war starts but the
Iron Man poster is bugging you it is an
angle there we go
okay thank you um my guitar case is
sitting right next to it so chances are
it probably fell into it or something
like that but it should be straightened
out now like I hope you're not bugged
anymore
let's see how much explain what it's
like we gotta scroll back up again okay
what is a popular comic book event or
run that everyone loves but you may
think is overrated or just disliked
spider-verse everybody loves
spider-verse I thought spider-verse
sucked like nothing happened I was like
you know what like all the spider-man
are like oh my god these like five guys
are chasing us and killing us off so
let's all band together but as soon as
one shows up let's run away like I was
like okay this is dumb like I I didn't
like spider personal spider-verse just
felt like a way for Marvel to come along
and say okay guys look the incursians
are happening I guess we could just
chalk up the death of all the spider-man
to the incursians but we've got to like
like fans are gonna want to know what
happens to all these I've in spider-man
they don't want to know what happens to
like all these different characters plus
there's some we might want to bring in
so let's just like create this big event
that was totally unnecessary like I
wasn't a big fan of spider-verse at all
who do I think the strongest character
in DC Marvel Universe are we talking
about right now or are we talking about
like this ever existed because we're
talking about any like the strongest
character who's ever existed in DC and
Marvel I'd say probably Superman 1
million which Superman prime hmm but
even then there's characters he can go
against sir they could go against him I
mean let's say like not oh no problem
probably not Galactus Galactus hope we
couldn't do anything against him his
Superman problem was God level Superman
if I remember that correctly somebody
make sure I'm right if it's like
Superman 1 million or Superman Prime or
if they're both the same person I can't
remember I've taught my hand I think
it's Superman 1 million though um hmm
Superman 1 million and maybe the Living
Tribunal I think would be a good match
up
hmm are you excited for Batman vs
Superman
yeah heck yeah I'm excited for Batman vs
Superman I'm gonna go see it
I mean I don't know why I wouldn't um
yes Tyrell Jones it is my birthday
yes I'm gonna go see it I mean I I don't
know why I wouldn't I'm actually pretty
excited to see Ben Affleck playing
Superman I'm Henry Cavill was yeah he
was all right but he was a product of
okay so promise you'd made 1 million or
different okay um well Henry Cavill was
a product of I guess is just not very
good writing so I think that that we've
been half like Madison crap shoot Ben
Affleck could be astounding as Batman or
he could be a total catastrophe
he's obviously demonstrated he's a great
actor like he's a really really good
actor I mean I mean look at like look at
what was it the town Argo Good Will
Hunting I mean he's just got like a back
of that catalog of great films I'm gone
girl I mean he's gotta back about
catalog was just amazing films that were
absolutely solid but I think that if the
story's written bad and of his
characters written bad people are gonna
say he's a terrible Batman as opposed to
that Batman was written like crap
because non comic-book fans don't
differentiate they don't know to
differentiate see like a lot of you guys
who are avid DC fans who were getting in
the new 52 right when it launched knew
that when like the Man of Steel came out
you said okay this is new 52 Superman
this is not classic Superman people who
didn't read the comics to look to that
in the sent of Superman he's the Man of
Steel you know I mean he has this whole
thing truth justice the American Way I
think was his catchphrase that's the
Superman they imagined the red suit or
the blue suit and the red tie tore the
red underwear like that was their
Superman that's the only Superman they
know because they don't they can't
differentiate between you know Golden
Age Superman Post Golden Age Superman
Silver Age Superman pre-crisis Superman
post-crisis Superman you know new 52
Superman they don't know all that stuff
they just see you Superman
and
like Superman you know that's the kind
of problem that Ben Affleck is gonna
have if they write in like new 52 Bruce
Wayne people are gonna say okay well
this is obviously not Frank Miller's
Dark Knight Returns this is not that
version they're not they're not gonna
know that they're just gonna say Batman
like Bruce Wayne he's a billionaire he
dresses up as a bat and he fights people
I mean whatever like that's that's what
they're gonna see and so they're gonna
say he's a terrible Batman as opposed to
they wrote a crappy version of Batman
but you know and nonetheless I mean new
52 Batman's Austin like it's amazing you
know Scott Snyder's done a great job but
let's see Dormammu Tryg enormous fist Oh
Dormammu hands down her momma would
would obliterate all like he's stupidly
powerful I think there was a point it
was Oh God
strange tales no was a strange tales I
think he showed up after strange tales
maybe it was his solo series issued like
31 or something I on the board it was um
Doctor Strange was like if Dormammu
showed up in this reality no one could
stop him like he would kill everybody
like there's nothing we'd be able to do
which is a pretty big deal like if they
were like a fully powered door mommy
would be able to obliterate all around
happy birthday thank you would you like
to see Wildcats live-action movie or do
you think it would be better for
something on Netflix um a wildcats are
you talking about the cartoon show like
the two cats but the pilots like that's
what you're talking about let me know
that's what you're talking about do I
think Jay Garrick has a chance of
showing up and like in the comics in the
season finale of the flash TV series I
don't know because he were to deal I
assume you're talking about the flash of
two earths here was a deal for those of
you guys who don't know about the flash
of Tours this was was DC creating their
multiverse this was the first time the
multiverse ever popped up in DC Comics
the flash of to earth basically told us
yes Wally West is the current version of
flam sorry Barry Allen is the current
version of flash but there's also like
Golden Age flash Jay Garrick like he is
no wait a minute yeah yeah Jay Garrick
he is the Golden Age flash and so he
exists in his own parallel reality
there's no I mean as far as they said in
the TV show there was no flash before
this one like there there wasn't there's
never been a flash before and so they've
never seen this thing before so I don't
know how they would base it off unless
they said oh hey like yeah there was a
flash before Barry Allen it's just
nobody knew who he was or knew that he
was there I can't I can't imagine them
doing that like it wouldn't make any
sense about what they could do is they
could simply say okay like Jay Garrick
is Barry Allen in a different reality
like in a different reality Jay Garrick
became the flash instead of Barry Allen
they could do it that way and that would
be a great tip of the hat to a lot of DC
fans and saying yes Jay Garrick does
exist in this multiversal you know
landscape of the DC TV shows he's just
not the Golden Age flash now some really
hardcore DC fans would flip their [ __ ]
that's because they don't know because
they're so set in their ways they can't
accept change but um I think that for
the most part most people most DC fans
would say well that's cool you know and
just kind of go from there and they
would get more into it because it BDC
basically saying like hey guys like look
we recognize some of the fan favorite so
you guys have love for all these years
and they're still here you know it's
just they're playing in a different
capacity than they normally would have
done in the regular landscape I'm
excited for the excited for the
Fantastic Four movie do I think they'll
introduce Galactus Annihilus or maybe
even crossover the x-men honestly I
think you're given Fox way too much
credit here if Fox wouldn't know what to
do with a nihilist if they if they if
they use them at all like they would
just say oh here's a green alien that
it's powerful and wants to fight the
Fantastic Four and let's just make them
fight I don't think we're good Galactus
I don't think we'll get a nihilist I
mean it'll be them versus Doctor Doom
honestly I'm not really sure how I feel
about a Fantastic Four film I mean I
really want to see it I really want to
go watch it it's just I'm not going in
with a high expectation I'm going in and
expecting a stereotypical Fox screw-up
like that's that's kind of what
I'm expecting for Fox to just kind of
screw it up but at the end of the day
the fact that I'm going to see it is the
only thing that Fox cares about they're
like hey man as long as people pay money
to go see this we don't care what you
think about it so that's pretty much it
which is a really bad attitude to take
because that's how you destroy a
franchise so um let's see the new 52 is
a good source material for movies I mean
I like it more than other multiverses
but I guess it could be more restraining
um the new 52 so here's a problem a lot
of older is kind of crazy things if
people are getting into DC Comics now
new 52 is where they start and they say
oh new 52 is awesome but this is so cool
on me on I'm basically reading Superman
from Year Zero you know it's really
really nice a lot of the older DC comic
fans hate new 52 and they hate new 52
because all the continuity that they
loved all those stories they loved are
gone which is not an unreasonable stance
to take it's not unreasonable to say
they character that you've read for the
last 20 25 30 years doesn't exist
anymore and it makes you angry that's
very reasonable
which is why convergence is happening in
the first place it's DC saying okay guys
look we know you guys loved pre new 52
stories so here you go here's just a an
event with a ton of pre new 52 stories
now some of the stories are stupid I
don't know why they're doing some of
those stories but you know they're like
hey guys here you go read these stories
and and it'll be basically us going back
to the great day but after this like
we're done we're not going back to those
anymore it's all new 52 from this point
going forward so it's it's basically
DC's you know final hurrah to the pre
pre flashpoint era of DC comics but I
think that going forward I mean new 52
is gonna have to be the source of
material for for DC stuff because you
know those are the guys who are really
new 52 now if you watch a movie about or
watch a TV show about a DC comic book
character and he's part of the new 52
but the story you're being given in the
TV show is not the new 52 story you're
gonna be confused you're gonna say well
this is weird like why is this I don't
understand
you know if they go back to pre new 52
it's gonna confuse a lot of people so I
think the new 52 is it's pretty much
where you want to start with us it's
pretty much where you want to go with
with the whole DC thing um
winnie-the-pooh explained
oh so I catch ya that's what that was
that's what that was I never read
Wildcats um I don't know I know it's
gonna be in convergence which I'm
actually kind of interested to see that
whole thing um it'll it'll see that's
gonna be the really cool thing guys is
there's a lot of you guys who are who
have read this stuff in the past you
guys are gonna love our videos about or
left my videos about convergence because
this is all gonna be new to me this is
this is this is gonna be my first time
going through and reading these stories
like reading about these characters
because I in the 90s it was x-men for me
it wasn't until new 52 that I started
getting into DC Comics and then I
decided reading DC pre new 52 you for a
lot of the videos that we did but I was
never an avid pre flashpoint DC fan that
was never my bread and butter mine was
Marvel back in the day and so I think
you guys are gonna love love our videos
because there's gonna be a lot of holy
cow moments and wow that was kind of
weird and I'm like what what's important
this character woman sitting on things
like that it'll be a lot of those and so
I think you guys will find I think you
guys will be able to look at me going
through these videos and say that was
you back when you were first reading
these things it'll be a great I think a
nostalgia experience in a lot of ways
but nonetheless um yes I've read rage of
Ultron and it was alright he was decent
enough um let's see Rob eating pudding
explained make a video of myself just
eating pudding and like this is
delicious pudding and the putting his
gun business in that net what two major
stories from The Avengers and Justice
League what I like to see is animated
films ooh that's a good one
well the Justice League I'm not sure
because I'm not as familiar with stories
about the Justice League oh he's not
questioning you guys you guys asked me
you guys tell me what Justice League
story out of all the DC Justice these
what story would you like to see turn
into
animated film with regards to the
Avengers that I'm a lot more familiar
with this may be kind of weird this may
be kind of silly and some folks may be
like what but I would like to see
operation galactic storm turn into an
animated film like that was a great
story
I loved operation galactic storm that's
way back and Children's Crusade would
make a good film too but I think I mean
I like the the old-school stuff so I'd
say operation galactic storm I don't a
lot of you guys are just like what's
that like I don't understand what what's
operation galactic storm like what in
the world is going on let's see
did you enjoy the Shadowlands event for
daredevil and what did you think of him
killing bullseye I actually haven't read
it I'm not currently daredevil but I
need to be robbing guardians of the
galaxy were to fight Howard the Duck and
Batman who would win Batman has an hour
prep but guards of the galaxy can call
and Deadpool for help that's
ridiculously unfair okay
the guardian of the galaxy can not call
into it but I'm gonna amend your thing
alright Batman still gets an hour of
prep time but well no okay fine yeah
okay they can call him Deadpool um okay
Batman gets an hour of prep time and
he's with Howard the Duck and guarding
to the galaxy have Deadpool uh alright
Batman creates a ray that neutralizes
the healing factor of Deadpool
he shoots Deadpool dad pulls out of the
picture so now it's Batman and Howard
the Duck vs. guardians of the galaxy um
I can't think of a way that madmen be
able to shield himself from the elements
of star-lords elemental gun so he dodges
that consistently he can't go he can
probably go against crude but goo be
tough so let's say he fights like he
immediately goes into star-lord fights
star-lord right off the bat steals his
gun freezes group using the gun or let's
say this burns groot let's say he liked
it uses fire and burns groot to the
ground so now grits dead like he's
literally just been burned
let's say that Gamora is going against
Howard the Duck Howard's duck dies I
mean why would he live so so we've got
Batman vs star-lord Gamora
um and Drax the destroyer
Batman has an hour of prep time Batman
presses a button on his on his belt and
the entire bat family arrives so now
we've got Batgirl we've got Nightwing
we've got Red Hood we've got Damian
Wayne and we've got Red Robin finding
alongside Batman
all of them overpower the remaining
guardians of the galaxy the only
exception is is let's say Drax the
destroyer because Jax of Astoria we
easily be able to take on the entire bad
family and then some and so he takes out
the entire bat family so right now it's
Batman versus Drax a destroyer
so Batman's fighting your action destroy
your Batman's being overpowered he
presses a button again on his utility
belt Superman shows up Superman pummels
Drax the destroyer tears his head off
Batman wins done and done next question
so alright can you further explain Adam
warlock hmm I mean I don't know how else
how much more we can go into him I don't
know
hey carded to be actually called Adam
warlock fight over see what do I think
it about family I think the bat family
is kind of cool I mean I think I think
the Red Hood is the coolest member of
the bat family like I love redheads
character but you know the bat family is
pretty decent
damn Rob this is new 52 Superman he
didn't mind killing people let's see
it's quick some of the fastest speedster
in the Marvel Universe um yes and no
he's not as fast as somebody who's using
the time Jim the runner I think it was
but it actually took not time Jim um
the space Jim the Runner was using the
space Jim and he was able to
subconsciously like teleport mm-hmm so
he wasn't really like running per se
he was teleporting like he knew where he
wanted to be and he would instantly be
there like Thanos had said you're not
really running like you're teleporting
so that's not really not really running
I'd say that if you're talking about
like literally feet to the ground and
running in a direction the probably
Quicksilver but the runners still like
he's an elder of the universe so he's
probably he may be faster we've ever
stood a race between the two and we've
never seen the runner where he was
literally running from one place to
another we've ever seen that so it's
really hard to gauge Hyperion is better
than Superman uh I don't know about that
like I don't know about all that
Hyperion solid but yeah Jason Todd Red
Hood
who do I think should play Hugh or play
Wolverine after Hugh Jackman mm-hmm I
don't know um I mean that's that's a
problem with the care to see I think
that's what Hugh Jackman was afraid of
nothing anybody would not be able to
play the character after him but that
people would say like who else could
play Wolverine except for Hugh Jackman I
think was afraid of getting typecast um
the Wizards fast were he's not that fast
he's not nearly as fast as Quicksilver I
think that I don't know I mean so here's
here's a problem though with with Hugh
Jackman even playing Wolverine in the
first place one Wolverine is supposed to
be short and he's supposed to be bulky
these will be short and huge in size and
I can't think of anybody in Hollywood
who's short and massive in size most
people who are really really bulky and
muscular are tall like they're big like
great big people I don't know I have no
earthly clue who would play Hugh Jackman
or play Wolverine besides Hugh Jackman
and Nikki Nicolas Cage is huge it is a
Wolverine no way is Deadpool immune no
Deadpool was given his healing factor
due to the Weapon X with an X program
see do you consider Superman as a cosmic
being within the realm of DC Comics I
guess if he were thrust as the Marvel
Comics certainly he'd be a cosmic level
being because his power is on such a
high level that there are very few
people that could physically challenged
him but I'd say within the realm of DC
and see I'm not really sure how the
whole cosmic being a thing is set up in
DC Comics they do some research on that
first I mean I know that they have stuff
like I think the new gods there's
something like that I'm not a hundred
percent sure about that I know that was
like Kirby's idea way back in the day or
I guess you wanted to expand on it and
everything but I'm not a hard person
sure Danny DeVito Danny DeVito as
Wolverine will be hysterical Superman vs
Deadpool woo we should do a video about
that like a versus video like oh I might
do that I might do that just like hey
guys this is a one-off this
just for fun like we're probably never
gonna do this again and just do Superman
vs Deadpool like Deadpool can heal from
anything but can Superman kill him or
would he kill Superman that would be
such an awesome video like that would be
cool let's see my favorite villain and
hero in both DC and Marvel ooh favorite
villain and hero in both DC and Marvel
well with DC Comics one of my favorite
villains one of the villains that I
think it's probably the best villain
that that DC has at least in my opinion
is Lex Luthor and that's because Lex
Luthor is the embodiment of what happens
when you have a man who's pushed to the
limit and who will never stop pursuing
the idea of another human being who will
basically who he's the epitome of what a
human being could be and I think that's
what makes Lex Luthor so attractive to a
lot of kind of book readers because they
say wow I guess he's just a guy like
he's just a man who's just super smart
and really really wealthy in terms of
Heroes and DC Comics uh probably
probably Batman because again he's just
kind of a guy who's really rich and has
a lot of gadgets in terms of Marvel I
would say huh hmm a little more
complicated a favorite hero in Marvel
probably Captain America because of the
fact that his resolve just doesn't break
like he he he always believes and he
always believes in the right thing like
he always believes that what he's doing
is right
which regardless of whether or not he is
I think that it's still you know I think
that's still a good call you know on
behalf of his character in terms of
villains um I would say Magneto and
here's why magneto magneto I think is
probably the greatest villain in Marvel
Comics and the reason why is because
magneto is a guy who's ruled by his past
like magneto cannot get past the fact
that mutants were persecuted that
mutants are being persecuted in the
Marvel Universe but what he does is he
superimposes his experiences in Nazi
Germany on to the relationship between
mutants and humans and then goes forward
and so what he's doing is he's not
really fighting on behalf of mutants
he's fighting against Nazis that don't
exist anymore
like that's what he's doing and that's
why I think his character is so dramatic
and so dynamic is because he's a guy who
just can't move forward like he just
can't step forward he's just constantly
rule about what happened in the past
um let's see Captain America the movies
is awesome like he's amazing all right
guys we're gonna do this for about
another five five or ten minutes and I'm
gonna go ahead and bounce off here
because I need to get to get to work I
need to get some food in me and get to
work on our video for tomorrow
well maybe not tomorrow probably do a
video on Tuesday I need a break for
tomorrow but let's see Captain America
and the Green Lantern Corps oh my god
could you imagine like Captain America
in the Green Lantern Corps would be
pretty amazing
do Oh God doom is a great villain too
but I think magneto is is like in terms
of personality in terms of the character
I think Maggie knows it much better
villain now if we're talking about in
terms of just like going through and
just like making people's lives a living
hell oh it definitely dr. doom doctor
knew is a great thorn in everybody's
side like he's the doctor dorm does not
the doctor doom does not discriminate in
terms of the new nuisance that he makes
himself out to be with regards to
superheroes like he'll be coming he'll
be a pain in anybody's rear and it is a
matter for to matter to him let's see
who has more powerful heroes DC versus
Marvel oh definitely Marvel Marvel has
more godlike level characters but DC has
more I guess less godlike level
characters I mean you got to think about
it Marvel has the century they have blue
Marvel they have Hyperion those are just
three versions of Superman in Marvel
Comics like Marvel has Power Girl
I guess I have Supergirl they have
Superman but at the end of the day like
you've got
best magic here at the end of the day I
mean you've got cosmic level entities
you've got to be honest you've got the
Beyonder you know the one from Secret
Wars you've got the one above all you
got Living Tribunal you've got Galactus
you've got eternity infinity beyond
let's see you got quasar you got I mean
you have all these like cosmic level
characters Adam warlock Thanos - so on
like I would say by leaps and bounds
Marvel has far stronger characters than
DC Comics which I like cosmic level
characters um let's see who is Lady Thor
we don't know we have no idea who Lady
Thor is no earthly clue we might do a
video on blue Marvel now that I think
about it
they have Manhunter here that's true
read uncanny Inhumans zero finally find
out what happened after infinity okay so
does that tie okay because I know that
he was my problem with with infinity
infinity like we had the Infinity event
and then if I remember correctly Black
Bolt detonated the inherit of the tears
and bomb and so then we had the Terrigen
mist spread throughout the world and
then we jumped in humanity which was
like oh my god there's all these humans
popping up and then inhuman picks up
after inhumanity and then Black Bolt
disappears because of the incursions and
he's working with the Illuminati yeah
I'll definitely check out uncanny
Inhumans number zero then if that's the
case because I love the Inhumans like I
think it humans are fantastic
let's see please explain Rob's birthday
radioactive exposure for another planet
travelled through a different time and
dimension or created in a lab by
experimental government organization to
dominate YouTube all the above can I
call Sal and Tiffany I mean I guess we
could call Sal see what sounds doing
maybe he'll answer let's
so maybe maybe he'll pick up we'll see
what's up if you can change how Deadpool
kills Deadpool how would you end it I
wouldn't have the story in the first
place
blue Marvel vs. the Sentry vs. King
Hyperion what Sal's not answering for
some reason says he's calling but it's
not panning out well there was no answer
so I assume he's just really really busy
um let's see
please don't call Chris Evans has one
movie left after Civil War do you think
he might die at the end of Civil War and
then be resurrected for Avengers
infinity war no I don't think so I think
they're gonna kill Chris Evans often I
think Sam Wilson is gonna take his place
as as all-new Captain America so like I
think I think that's very much the
direction they're gonna be going in
upset about Kentucky losing yeah I'm
upset about Kentucky losing why would
not be like that was my team let's see
Punisher vs. Moon Knight vs. Red Hood Oh
God
Punisher vs. Moon Knight versus Red Hood
see I love like these versus things that
you guys come up where they crack me up
Punisher vs. moon knife vs. Red Hood hmm
well more expected would be taken out
almost immediately there's no way
there's no way mark Spectre could hang
with Punisher in and and Red Hood like
no possible way
I mean Punisher would just shoot him as
soon as he saw him and like no questions
asked
Red Hood would be able to dodge out of
the way because Red Hood has all the
training of Batman and then some let's
see ooh
honestly I'd say Red Hood probably went
out between against the Punisher because
Frank Castle does not have the kind of
training that Red Hood has me Red Hood
was trained by super I'm sorry by Batman
when he was Jason's hard plus he had all
the training that he got at the hands of
some of the world's best uh I guess
tactician xand hand-to-hand combat
weapons used I guess
explosives all different kinds of stuff
so I'd say most likely Red Hood would
take the whole thing but anyway guys um
we're gonna go ahead and in this so
here's here's what's coming up so we're
definitely gonna work on do some more in
Cu timeline videos and here's a really
cool thing going forward with the MCU
timeline this is when we're really gonna
get into a lot of the stuff that's
happening in the movies that we're gonna
be able to fill in the gaps between the
movies and we're gonna talk about stuff
that's going on behind the scenes in the
movies because while one movies
happening there's other stuff taking
place that ties into other movies in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
so we're definitely going to do some
more of those MCU timeline videos we're
gonna talk about war machine we're gonna
talk about Black Widow we're do videos
on them we're gonna do videos on uh who
else we've already done Thor will
probably do a video on on Heimdall
probably the the cast of The Avengers 2
age of Ultron group as a whole and then
maybe a couple characters who are or
smaller characters in the film and then
after that we're gonna start doing
videos are gonna lead us into time runs
out we're still going to cover
convergence we're gonna have convert
this number one is videos that we're
gonna do so we're gonna be chock full of
stuff over the course of the next few
months or so so it's gonna be gonna be
pretty crazy but what was your question
char's I can I'm sorry I didn't answer
your question what was your question
I'll wait here patiently until you ask
your question and then I'll bounce off
here so but but we're gonna be really
really like hammering out a whole bunch
of different stuff we're gonna be away
tour we're gonna be working our butts
off for for all that stuff for
convergence and like Secret Wars and
moving people's comments and all kinds
of stuff so let's see people are like
happy birthday let's see
well that chars I can do is not
answering this question so alright guys
well um yeah I'm gonna bounce off here
so oh if you guys want to know how it
was at me and the weekly pool guys got
together go check out the podcast okay
where's George skins question what would
be your ultimate team matchup mixing DC
and Marvel characters who would they
fight again oh my god okay
um we're gonna have to do that like
another time because that's a really
really in-depth question or maybe maybe
we'll do a video about that best of DC
versus the best of Marvel and see who
wins anyway I'm gonna go ahead bounce
off here guys be looking out for those
videos that we talked about and and yeah
so I'll catch you guys later peace